suis dit je vais un petit peu inquiété
et j'ai découvert quelque chose donc
savez à quel point il aime les hommes
donc du coup il aime les femmes il aime
l'être humain comme je vous l'aï dit au
début
et il existe des femmes
qui ont certains désirent voilà les
désirs de la vie des choses qu'on ne
contrôle pas qui se passe dans le
cerveau dans le coeur il ya des femmes
comme beaucoup d'hommes parme qui aiment
les pieds il se frotte à des pieds mais
il ya des femmes qui se prend à des
camions quoi ouais c'est ce qui est en
train de dire canivez d'aurélie c'est
qu'il y aurait des femmes qui vous
demandait de se frotter à votre câble
obtenu c'est vrai que ça existe c'est
vrai oui
c'est déjà arrivé c'était j'arrive déjà
arrivé la femme est bien excité bas
c'est lui qui se frotte à l aube aux
caméras
mais bon c'est à balles réelles je vais
citer dominique baudis baudis calomnie
quel l'omni internationale mais vous
savez que vous attaquez
je sais pas ça